Okay, let's start.
Last time you beat a seeking and that's about it, right?
We didn't really do any rest.
We just did little shopping and the seeking fight.
We got a phone call from Black Hand.
We got a phone call from Greenline.
Yeah.
So, Spirit lives, the marine base has a marine base.
He told you to be careful and what did I say eight hours or something, right?
So I'd say you are well rested and it's like maybe the morning.
What are all of you doing?
What is everyone doing on the ship?
Everybody bright and early with the soothing sound of backlips from the very topic process.
All right.
Get back where it is happening.
We can hear you well.
Okay.
All right.
I think that's better.
I'm cooking everybody breakfast and making a little something on the side for myself.
All right.
I'll just be here and substitute myself with my engineers.
Okay.
The black ring that you got from the Kiro hideout.
Why didn't we get a ring?
Check your inventory.
So are you going to give him the ring?
Yeah.
I'm going to give him the ring.
All right.
I'm going to go back to his station and pull out like a microscope kind of thing from one of his bags and he's just going to just look over the ring.
If there's like any carvings or stuff like that on the ring.
All right.
I'm going to get your food.
I'm just going to stop some seeking.
I'm probably have the sampling for the blood done and he's going to say, okay, it's fine to eat as long as it's cooked.
Okay.
Nice.
Right after we've got it.
I forgot if sapling revealed her real voice or not.
As you guys are like having breakfast, I don't know if red is going to partake and have any trust in.
I'm looking anymore, but that's a bit.
A little bit of seeking.
That piece are you are you having seeking are you vegetarian? I don't know.
You just see a plate disappear, but you never see him come in there.
As the ship crests like a final wave, you see spirit clips come into view towering slate colored cliff rising like an ancient guardian from the sea fog rolls in low along the base of the ocean.
Above it all nestle between like the wind horn arches and stone outcroppings.
You see a bustling coastal settlement clipping to the side clinging to the side of the cliff.
Let me show you an image if I did not show you that.
It's the layout of the region.
Let me see.
Can you guys see this here?
You see long cranes, whole cargo between tears of wooden walkways while some workers are shouting across police systems and road bridges.
You see a massive marine flag slapping around it like a watch tower near the eastern ridge.
The basically and mistickable sign of navy presence. You spot a chain of colorful buildings, taverns, markets and out of place casino.
Let between even in the daytime.
You see farther off shipyards with a bunch of activity.
Basically the one if you can see near like the right side, there are some dogs and there's on the left side near the marine base.
There are some dogs.
You've been told to go towards the right side so the marine ship does not spot you.
Yeah, and you basically when you get close to the place you see a big sign that says brambles and brothers.
Let me move to the next scene.
Satellill direct the ship to the right so they don't get spotted by you know Marines.
So as you start to roll your ship in, say your ship, I'm sorry.
To the dogs you see a bunch of workers just working around moving crates and stuff.
You see let me see if I can reveal his.
I don't have this full image. You see just a big guy maybe it probably like some 75 or 76 just standing there and talking to a bunch of workers on the dogs.
And as soon as you like move your ship in, he spots you and he's going to yell that.
Just leave that there. Come out.
What are you guys going to do?
As as Satellill finishes more on the ship.
She'll begin to move forward.
And yes, she is still in our armor.
Lynn is going to also move towards the outside and he's just going to drop down.
He's just going to sit somewhere on this railing.
Just to listen in because he doesn't really have anything to do here.
I'm just going to follow up over here.
Everyone's at their place, right? Okay.
Brambler is going to do a go.
Maybe we should take this inside.
That is workers to go back to work or go get on the ship and move it to some place safe.
Do you have any objections to that? Is up there any of the crew?
Because they're going to take your ship away for storing it someplace where the Marines can see it.
Yeah, and we were told to meet with Brambler.
Yes.
Then yeah, Satellill will not object.
The ship away.
Go go right ahead.
Three people in front of Brambler are going to move your ship outside of.
All right, step right in.
He's going to tell you to follow him back into the.
I can't.
And it's also going to fall.
Anybody else go in there?
That's a wall.
We can.
Now you can move inside as much as it wants.
Brambler is going to go.
Right.
Right hands get some.
I suppose.
You need.
I am the dread not.
Yeah, the news travels quick.
Red note.
Red.
I presume.
Roma.
And.
Baptiste or something.
I've heard about you from here.
I didn't see you in the papers.
I'm going to show you.
And Linus.
Go to you to show your face again.
Linus is just going to show it off.
And he's going to say I'm just here to observe.
Brambler.
I'm calling.
Is it Linus?
We've been calling him.
Yeah, he said you can call.
Yeah, we've known his name is Linus this entire time.
Yeah, he's still.
You just.
Almost.
Okay.
In character.
You're saying this.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's fine.
Brambler is going to go.
Oh.
Sure.
Call him whatever you want.
His name is Linus.
I mean, it's going to say.
Yeah.
My name is Linus.
The actual name.
I don't just don't like people calling me that.
I don't know.
No, I'm all confused.
Fuck you.
Brambler is going to go.
That's unusual for you.
I was going to go.
All right.
Back to business.
You don't told me you need a ship.
Ship good enough to.
I don't know if you can.
Sorry.
We got three weeks of food, let's go.
That's wrong.
Well, I need an item retrieved.
Well, it's not a good design, retrieving, it's more like stealing but you know.
Anyway, have you heard all night that loud?
Can't see that I have.
All right, you are pirates, I suppose.
Well, the Wargoman bank is a bank that stores money.
But I don't need the money.
This is not a bank hoist because that'd be stupid.
What I need is an item, a small chest, retrieved from the cabin of the director of the branch
of Wargoman bank in Spiritscrufts.
Did somebody write this down?
I'm sorry, that was a lot of word.
Okay, well, anyone understands what I'm saying.
Indeed.
All right.
What do you want this chest for?
That quite literally is not my business.
Well, here are your options.
You can go at any point, I mean, preferably in the night, infiltrate, get the chest.
It's not going to be easy.
There's marine patrols throughout the city.
There's marine patrols inside the bank.
As long as you don't go near the wall, you should be fine.
But the director's cabins are also pretty secure.
Lucky for you, I have a blueprint.
Me and my ancestors have been working on a spare cliffs for about a hundred years.
So we got the layout of the place.
I can tell you where the director's cabin is, but that's about it.
There's no secret entrance.
There's nothing.
You go in from the front door.
You get the thing, you go out to the front door.
Is there a bad only thing?
Is there a bathroom in the bank?
Probably.
I mean, there's a shithole.
I thought you'd have four glue prints.
You should know if there's a bathroom.
There's a shithole.
What do you mean a bathroom?
What's a bathroom?
You haven't heard of a bathroom.
Is there, oh, I guess there's the fucking mehawk bathroom.
Is that a bathroom?
Yeah, bathrooms exist in one piece.
Oh, I keep forgetting this is not the end.
Bathrooms are a very old concept in one piece, probably.
Yeah.
All right.
Yeah, there's a bathroom.
I just call it the shithole.
All right.
So yeah, one more thing.
The director frequents the local casino.
So one way could be maybe get the director drunk, maybe get the keys from him, maybe disguise
yourself as one of his people, get into his cave and get the thing, get out.
But those are your options.
You feel free to do whatever you want.
Well, I'm going to head out.
I'm going to take care of some business.
If you need me, just shout.
I'll be out there.
You guys can discuss this within yourself if you're ready to take up the job or not.
It's going to head out.
Yeah.
Now, here's the real question.
Are any of us here particularly stealthy?
I think red is.
Red has invisibility.
Yeah.
So I'll come that as strength.
Oh, sorry, stealth.
I don't know what I'm saying.
That, okay.
What an image.
Or a farm.
Yeah, they also have me in hand.
Oh, or a farm is different from being stealthy.
Yes.
I mean, stealth is quite literally not an option for you and Baptiste.
And even Roma, he's pretty big.
Hey, hey, I got plus two to sell.
Sure, but you are huge man.
I'm a fat nimble.
I can be stealthy.
Yeah, you can be stealthy.
It's just as long as no one spots you.
You're good.
That's what I mean.
It's like, take it up.
It's like take it up.
Apologic out of the real chair.
Yeah.
I have a plan.
We take the two small.
We take the two smallest people.
Okay.
We have them sitting in the bathroom at the bank.
When the bank closes, they get out.
They get out of the room.
We have a.
An unstealthy.
Guys will be posted up inconspicuously around the bank.
I'll be a bomb sleeping on the street corner.
Somebody can be doing something else.
So if there's something that goes down, we're all around.
All right.
And then they take a blueprint with them.
So they know where to go inside the bank.
And then they go.
Well, that sounds great and all.
But.
I.
It's through there.
Get it for us.
Get back.
Well, first of all, I'm not involved.
I don't want to rob the world government bank.
I don't work for you.
I'm just here to get my stuff.
I'm going to go to the people that I want to meet here and then just, you know, say goodbye.
You just heard about the job.
You just heard about it.
That makes you in.
You're not part of it.
I don't think it's.
It works.
Hey, we got to tie you up then.
We got to put you someplace.
That way you don't.
You.
You're quite literally cannot grab it.
He's like made to not be grabbed.
I'm a huge creature.
No, no, no, no, I'm talking about Lynn.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
You can.
You can just pass through you.
You can't grab.
But yeah, okay.
So you're going to grab Roma.
Do you want to resist Roma or now?
No.
All right.
I'm going to go.
I'm going to grab him.
No.
All right.
They're grabbed.
Grab him up.
Pull him back a bit.
Hey, man.
I'm just saying he heard our plant.
He could easily go tell the cop.
Look, you just don't let him.
No, no, no, you either not.
You're not big on Marines.
All right.
I just, I'm just here to meet the.
People that I want to meet and just.
I'm just here to meet the.
So, if the Intel is correct, you need to go to the casino, get the keys somehow. And then that might help you to get into his cabin at the Molgonman Bank.
Correct?
We got to get this man drunk, but how do we get him drunk?
Well, if you get to the table he's at, it's not going to be hard if you just win.
Who's getting a gamblet here?
Do you, and if you have like, proficiency in dice or playing cards?
Let me look.
Brad, how do you look?
There should be two proficiency.
If you do have them.
Nope.
He only has quibble hooks, you can sell it to our brothers.
I mean, I guess we can go of the old fashioned way, just play straight dice.
Uh, pure gamble.
Pure gamble.
Well, I can tell you the insights.
I've played there a couple of times, not to my surprise.
I lost all the money, but that's all I can say.
Uh, well, here's the deal.
You go in, uh, the final table is the poker table, right?
But before that, there's, if you get through the first two tables, which is one of them is just, uh, devil's dice, where you just roll the dice, get the highest, uh, number of the table.
Uh, number of the same amount of dice.
So that's your first game, the second game is back check.
And then you can get to the poker table.
Game.
So there's your option or you can just go straight to the world government bank, which I would advise against, but you're the one who stepped in with the huge fucking armor.
Well, I did meet it.
No, I know, I know.
Can you tell me more about your condition later? Maybe I could help.
Anyway, all right.
I'm gonna take my leave.
Do you have a chance to have a, I said a loaded dice on you.
Let me check.
After the gambling.
I saw never to gamble again.
I could win something up for that.
Well, that's it for me.
If you need my help, I'll be at the armada.
Lin is going to hand you a piece of paper that will give you directions to like his hideout.
And he's going to just say, I'll get my stuff from the ship about the ring.
Samplia.
If you could spare some time before going to your heist or whatever, come to the armada. I think we need to talk about this.
I'll keep sure we read a ring.
I'll be sure to hit there that.
I'm just going to walk through the wall and just get out.
All right.
So we got to get the dudes keys.
To get us through the bank.
Yes.
So, but to do that, we got to get the dude drunk.
And the only way to get him drunk.
Is to.
Get to the vocal table.
Maybe.
Maybe he's the kind of people person that gets it likes to get drunk when he loses.
Yeah.
Don't like it.
What one of you guys good with a bow can shoot a arrow at him that's dipped in.
Dipped in that.
No, no, he can't shoot me.
We are.
We are going to do an arrow at him.
I'm just saying we should.
Somebody.
She had like a lord or something that would make sense, but the arrow is a deal.
Hey, what if you could could you make a.
Some super alcohol or something?
That's what I'm trying to figure out.
We use that.
Because Lynn said the seeking is good if we cook it.
What does it do to you?
Bramble, Bramble walks in and he's like, you're not planning on killing the worry going banks director.
Are you?
No, but I'm hoping like he starts to throw up while we're like at the poker table.
And then we could go and be like, let's get him to a hospital and then carry him off.
But in reality, we're picking his pocket.
And he's too sick to realize what's going on.
No, as insane that it sounds.
You might be able to pull this off.
We'll be able to fill it off.
Yeah, there's just some we are a tiny girl with cat ears here now.
He's like, what the.
All right, I guess this is happening.
Hi there.
Well, just for black beer, black hand out.
I guess I have to keep this a secret as well.
What about your armor?
What are you talking about?
I don't know.
I'm the person that uses that armor.
So what you guys are confusing me?
He's stupid and wants to lie.
All right.
You have you're going to take the armor with you because I don't think we can move this thing out now.
Yep, I'll have to I'll have to be pilot and yet.
Yeah.
All right.
Well, good luck getting through the city with that.
But sure.
Take the armor.
If you want to meet Lynn because he said he'd meet you at some point.
You probably have the address.
Surprisingly, the casino is not far from the.
Hideout of the six folds.
So once you get to our motto, it should be close enough.
The game starts at four in the evening.
So you're going to have to wait.
I'm going to have to wait for you.
All right.
You got.
You got disguises for us.
Because obviously we can't be walking out there with one of your people is already in.
Cloak and I can't really see him.
Me or won't me about him.
I don't know who he is.
What he is.
But.
I could whip up some disguises.
I just need something to cover all of this.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh, as you have the rub.
All right.
I'll bring my boys in.
You can tell them what you need.
He's going to bring one of his workers in.
They're going to say, what do you need?
We need disguises because you know, we got.
We're in another brightest person in this place.
That's why I work here.
So what exactly do you need?
We need fake mustache shows and ponchos.
I want hats.
Fake one.
Mustache ponchos.
I had.
I'm going to look at red.
He's going to say, what do you need?
I just kind of look himself up and down.
Takes off his hat.
Just kind of looks.
Is this good?
All right.
I'm not.
He's going to go to a baptist and he's going to ask.
Do you need anything?
Fake-age patch.
Got it.
Money.
What do you say?
Give me all your money.
We need something here.
Rob is.
He's going to step back.
A bit by bit.
He's going to go to.
Bram was going to say, this is crazy.
Are you sure about this?
I was wondering where one of those track.
I'll get a track on hat.
Sure.
All right.
I'll get the stuff for you and he's going to leave.
And short after he's going to bring some stuff back.
I'm just going to give you a normal hat.
Give you some cloaks that could hide Roma.
He's going to give one to red too.
I'm just going to give you a mask.
It's inside Luciens, Kaben.
How the fuck do you get in there?
You only get in a way that you win big.
I just...
I guess we got to play.
He just...
We got to play the games.
We just each take our turns to see what we can do.
I've got to play the games.
Is that a nat one?
That is a nat one.
You know,
Safely knows how to look at this time.
Spot saplier and he's going to run towards
saplier is gonna say
stop right there
saplier is just gonna stand there still like a stax you
You see this marine looks a bit different than any of the marines you've seen before
is varying some kind of armor and the armor is going red
on the sides but the eyes are blue as he says
you to stop and he spots all of you he cannot make everyone out but he definitely knows who you are
he's gonna say jack come here uh he is so one of the other marines is also going to step in
and he's going to say uh whoa what what's the deal uh he's going to say don't you recognize that armor
um go wait someone just say it to stax you
uh who's gonna say it's stax you
uh no one's gonna say it's stax you okay here we go uh he's gonna
he's gonna pull out like uh uh a dendon mushy with like his mouth stretched out and like a piece
like a sheet in front of it and he's just going to click on it like tap on it and he sees
communicate when he pulls a in the mushy
it's not it's not the communication one it's just look out information uh so he he looks at it and he says
that's try not 50 million we should probably call for backup
but he's going to pull out two uh blades from both of his sides same as the other guy
and they're gonna go stay right there if you make any movements
we have to capture you forcefully give yourself sup
why do you have the time that was just standing there like a stax you
okay he's gonna just gonna look um red is just gonna look like really
shocked at these folks um it kind of makes little little birds out like that dread butt like pirate
we've been walking with pirate oh my good it kind of reaches out to touch sapalia and i'm gonna try
to cast invisibility on sapalia uh i don't think you can't go invincible in front of like other people
i don't think so no it's just straight up it physically
yeah it's still again if you disappear right in front of someone it doesn't do anything
it doesn't make sense i mean i'll be invisible they won't see me but uh they'll know i'm
i mean they know your location yeah okay so how do you cast invisibility
how does it work in one place i don't really understand let me let me see uh
a magical like hip bump like hey buddy
and let me check the sheet for invisibility some one piece with mumbo jumbo
yeah yeah make me invisible and make them think that their skits out okay let's say uh you you
play like a certain tune and for one second they are unable to like grasp the reality and they cannot
see sapalia anymore on your back pipe they blink yeah they blink what then he just disappeared
and you can cast invisibility on okay there you go yeah you can cast invisibility on other people
yeah i did it i did it it's invisible once i run invisible just gonna wait what happened
stop uh they're gonna run up to you as soon as you touch the
thing uh the sapalia and i guess roll for combat
you can't just disappear everyone is still here yeah yeah i kind of gonna be honest i didn't know
what the plan was there yeah i mean it's let's go
uh baptism you were still in hiding they can't
no no they can't see you can have me i thought they couldn't let me they just can't see uh
what's his name sapalia okay i'm gonna roll for the guys the fair warning if you don't get them in like
two turns they're gonna call for backup they're gonna be able to call for backup mid fight
no after check it out yeah we gotta see what these guys quick uh everyone's run for initiative right
yep yeah let's turn and let me begin to combat all right it's red's turn
hi robo just disappeared in front of them
they're like what the fuck happened wait did did you see it yeah i saw it
are we crazy what you're no no you're not crazy you're crazy you didn't see anything
why why would just like a 50 million battery of balance to be right there that you're crazy
you're crazy maybe we're just having a weird day anyway gas like drop gas like the red gas like
the red your bar put your hands up lie on the ground so we can cuff you your your bar ready gas like them
you can maybe do vicious not if you have a deal i don't think you do
anyway as soon as you touched him it was time for combat it doesn't it doesn't really help
red's looking kind of keep playing dumb
and just look the robot it's possessed it ran away magic everyone run for your lives i'm gonna try to run
uh okay sure sure okay let me away make a wisdom throw for these guys
damn damn both of them are dumb as breaks jesus christ uh they're like uh maybe we just let them get away
the other guy say it may maybe maybe we maybe we just missed out miss out what what happened
all right uh they're gonna not do anything while you run away red so you can make your full movement
i think that's 30 30-ish all right um you want a dash actually too no a dash
it's kind of way around the corner okay uh as you dash to this center of the market
you also see let me see how the fuck is the token where's the token go i thought i put it here
you see a small girl sitting in front here okay why why is there a name showing
do you see can you see the name
oh god damn it never just wait okay god okay now you can't that's fine
you see a small woman not taller than like four ten just sitting in front of the
stall and they and she sees you she says she goes where are you running to
uh let's let's move to the other guys if you can escape this somehow it's gonna be
looking crazy uh next is that he's youtube stop right there uh they're gonna pull out like
kind of like a ray gun from one of their holsters and they're gonna just
point it at both of you Roma and i think it's from around the corner
uh it's not the corner the this is like the in front of the shop it's like an open shop yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
uh baptizes your turn they don't need to stop they can't see oh one of them can see red okay how
man they aren't the droids you're looking for what would you say about this
but i get
these look no walk forward
and swing oh that's looking we're going oh swing
so that so that try out the one i did last time a regular let's do a knockout knockout
to the attack oh no it does not hit
as you uh try to hit him with the uh your arms he just blocks it when one of his hands and you
just bounce off the armor that they're wearing that's all i can do all right uh Roma it's your turn
well if we doing this i guess we are this then how far is that
that should be okay i guess i'm going to hit this dude all right
what does it act right with please go for it all right
that hits him
oh wait how much help does he have okay Jesus Christ how are you gonna uh do you do this
literally i'm running at him oh we didn't talk about this did we is there is there other people around
is there are definitely towns people looking at the fight okay
samplier has like she probably want to mention this in the boat trip she's been
intending to be like a non lethal person yeah she's a very pissed with Roma to already kill
the guy that they didn't need to kill so you know her intentions but it's up to you unless they're like
ultra evil she's not like super evil she's not she's not a killer but nah i'm gonna kill him
i ain't gonna kill him non lethal all right you're gonna just run up to him while he's distracted by
just baptized trying to hit the other guy he's distracted by that you run up to him you just
smack him in his face with the pan and his ghost down he's unconscious
uh do i do unconscious
you know what let's just lie no he's unconscious he's down
the other guy sees this and he's like what the fuck did you do uh is he the dead one no no he is
the could he's the dead him yeah the the guy who was who is now on down was his turn and now it's
samplier since we are well Biden sadly a will dunk dunk dunk dunk dunk and a
conscious guy from invisibility that's going to lift invisibility yeah it will break invisibility but
i will also have a bandit gun attack yes or unless y'all
grand unless y'all think you can handle these guys quickly
samplier is gonna come out of hiding we can handle them huh we do the what are you are you sure
yes okay then okay then we got that all right so what is samplier what's
that we will do is she'll 5 10 15 20 25 30 she'll begin making her way to where red went
5 10 red is not the red is here yeah you're the same oh okay okay yeah now i'm moving over there
so you're gonna dash yeah i'm dashing oh go okay dash 15 20 25 30 damn it
5 5 10 it's it's fine you can just do this like this that's 30 that's what i'm trying to do but it's
not letting me go through the damn building just drag i had to do it like this oh okay you can also
like control click and like do this dance press space and then do that if you yeah think it didn't
let me like drag through the building yeah yeah that's fine that's fine okay yeah samplier we'll go there
uh it's red's turn you're still in one of the uh visions of one of the guys so it's not out of
combat but as soon as you step out you're gonna be able to combat but there's yeah that's the only
guy left but just you see just one other person here they're not uh threatening or anything if
she's just confused that you were here red has just been kind of whole kind of old howl and
all like fingers up to her just kind of go just kind of try to hide around the corner of this building
all right she's gonna come up to you and she's gonna be like so who are we hiding from
which is like okay okay okay
and the the girl is like what the fuck did you hear that
what is happening here are things are I going finally bad
it's kind of shrugs like maybe okay uh so there's uh uh next is Baptiste
oh no no there's the guy he didn't no he died okay yeah that's fine Baptiste
sir turn after Roma then's the turn of the other guy like try this again
all right that will hit him okay
you're gonna make him unconscious right yes unfortunately okay how do you want to
knock him out after the miss map first punch he does come back
and just swings at the backhand
not go just not
so you just uh pinpoint the like plating between the neck and the armor behind uh his neck and
you just hit him there and he's gonna go down all right what are you gonna do with the bodies
and a lot of people looking around at you people watching yeah yeah for sure you're in the
literally the middle of the market they're not gonna do anything they're just gonna shut their doors
and just ignore it we got a ditcher behind the alley over here uh this girl is also going to
follow you guys in the street and the guy damn you guys took care of them huh uh the bodies up
onto the roofs you're just gonna dump the bodies on the roof are you sure you're gonna show your
wings in like a market place when you said everybody was leaving that's when I said no no no
that they're still looking at it but they're just closing their doors yeah
saffelia will snicker and say well that's my crew now you're still invisible right yes she is
too invisible okay the the girl is gonna go what the fuck is going on I keep hearing things
it's the gusset cats cats oh my god I am haunted no uh you
hear a guy screaming sarika where the fuck did you run off to uh you see a guy jumping from
roofs to roof and then she spots the girl and then he's gonna drop down it's like what the hell are
you doing here I told you to meet me at the marketplace at the town center uh hello why are you with
two minks what is happening why are the marines here did you do it you know we have a treaty right we
can't do this I told you to be careful uh they're gonna keep arguing and she's like I didn't do it
why did you put this on me every time it's not my fault okay this time for sure it's not my fault
they're gonna keep arguing about uh stuff oh let's get going then okay did you hear that
I found a couple trash cans okay now the both of them are talking about the voices they're here
saffelia saffelia gives her signature laugh
Jesus Christ okay they're gonna just jump back on the roof okay there's something wrong with
these people hey red will this armor fit you you're gonna strip them make it in front of the other
people yeah they won't know what we're gonna use this for okay how about you move this to an
alley or somewhere that people can see me yeah we're moving like we're moving like
this guy and the girl are going to just stand up there and just observe what's happening
they're or a farm and yeah she's gonna try to find a couple trash cans will leave these guys in
you probably spot some uh small trash cans that you can maybe push these guys in it's just not
going to be with their armor because their armor are pretty big
they have nice boots they do have nice boots well that's what I'm saying if this
hey this is how we can get even closer to the guy this is how we can get into the bank we
disguised as these two whose armor will this fit in who can fit into this armor uh I think red
can fit in that he's probably would not uh saffelia could fit in yeah saffelia could just modify
this armor into armor if you could use that yeah yeah you could do that but uh I'd need you to do like
do you have disguise kit or something for just wear an armor uh can you uh then you will have to
armor of magical strength yeah it's it's gonna be your infused item then you have to remove one of
your infused items no no I'm talking about my arcane armor like oh okay you're just gonna drop
the other one and then use this one like effect like effectively I'd swap out this the arcane armor
I'm wearing for this one okay that works that works but you probably could not do the process of
turning into your arcane armor in like two minutes so it's gonna be like oh no I could do it and
no I could do it 12 seconds is it it's just an action oh it is okay okay uh you want to do it
right now because then you can't do the armor not doing it right now but just in case okay so you
strip one of those guys and just pull the armor inside your armor yeah just keep it with you
okay let me remove one of those uh are you gonna look for anything else here
well we already searched them for everything right and we took their armor uh these two are going
to go back a bit and try now whisper to each other something uh you can't hear them um
sorry what are you doing you got one armor what about the next
hey what's right now sorry by anybody looking around anyone see me
uh no I mean uh this guy and this guy sees you this girl
these two these two can see you and I think the rest also no no yeah the rest can't
let's see if I can like swoop up a little just to overhear their conversation
oh their conversation uh okay what are the rest of you doing what what's up with the armor
one of them is going south leaf what I was thinking hear me out hear me out okay we we take this armor right
yeah whoever whoever this armor can fit with they respond to the bank like they got an alert that
it was getting robbed and they stand out on the outside waiting for us actual robbers to actually
robber and then they can come in and pretend to haul us off to jail knowing we already grabbed this
kit and I I could think of this armor real quick to make it it's a fittable for me yep and then the
other two here that aren't are going to be the ones robbing this place right and we're literally
just going to wait in the bathroom and tell the place closes and everybody leaves and then we just
walk up out the bathroom la di da my fat ass is going to be sleeping on the steps of the bank
right pat like pretending to be a bum passed out like cardboard over me like pretending to sleep
ask it spare change like oh this kid will work so the really fun thing about arcane armor is I
can exit it in an action change my arm other armor like the other armor into arcane armor in an
action and then just get into that in an action so the entire process takes 18 seconds
that's fine I'm just gonna say just for flavor I'd say if you get to Armada you'll have enough time
to tinker with the armor so it keeps you alive while you're in it yeah and you can move around
and stuff you can use all the abilities of that particular suit essentially how is there like
special stuff with this suit yes there's the two swords and the gun which is powered by the armor
if you use the gun without the armor they it won't work all right then yeah I'll say yeah I'll
save that for like when we're closer to the place okay these two guys are sending here red what are
you doing are you taking the other armor I think I mean I'm gonna be a robber I kind of do be
stealthy so I don't think I really need the armor okay yes I can bear the armor I don't think
anyone else can be here what kind of armor is it
sorry what you say as I was asking what kind of armor is it like stat wise like Shane
male plates it's it's like scale male no leather armor sorry it has the proficiency of leather armor
proficiency of leather armor okay so it will only have the easy for leather armor again okay it is
metal but it's pretty pain sheets of metal okay
if no one takes it then Brad's just going to catch which these guys boot so his feet feel
where he gets up all right he's like that's like stormtrooper armor essentially yeah actually
yeah all right so sorry one armor is with saplia you're gonna probably take the weapons of the
armor with you too and you have a small dendin mushy it's like a handheld dendin mushy one is like
a phone essentially one of them is like turn into a phone with the screen on it you can't use it
because it takes like face idea or whatever right so you can't open it but it's just there one is
like a dendin mushy like a radio shaped like a radio yeah and you can take that from the other guy too
if red and roll on are gonna let's just take in all of that okay
move taking the armor of the other guy yeah one set of armor I'll take the other set I'll dump it
you can okay okay so you dump both the bodies and the armor in the trash can and uh
that's it right but now I'm gonna take you said one of the face did in mushy was face recognition
yes right I'm gonna show it up show it to the face of the dude who's knocked out
uh the one that baptized knocked out probably has a distinguished little face so I think you can
use that on that one you uh you scan his face the the phone starts up it only has three
things on it it just says top bounties local reports and that and one more which is just uh connect to
commander sapling is gonna look at those bounties she she's curious at what top bounties are in the area
okay let me pull out it's going to be just the east blue the bounties for just the east blue
you see these two guys that are standing on the rooftops they have had bounties but their
bounties are now redacted it's like a black bar on their bounties but you see their names
their names are the guys named will Corvine ve yl Corvine and the other girl is named
cerica Corvine they seem to be siblings and there's not much information about it
other than the fact that they're from the six folds
sapling will just casually say while still invisible how are they're pronounced cerica
so uh she can probably yeah that's fine uh baptized was going to
listen in in the conversation right uh baptized can you roll for uh stealth for me
oh that was okay that's that's successful okay uh you you over here them talking about
wait are these the pirates that Linus said would be dropping by
the guy says the girl says sorry the guy says oh maybe i don't think we should worry about them
though they don't seem to know us we should just dip uh that's all they're talking about
not not much of any use and saplinga says uh how are you cerica and then she's like what the fuck
now i'm hearing my name what is happening uh she said she says oh she says oh hey there
what was the guys they have again uh whale yeah oh hi there whale and savića
she's gonna go okay something spooky going on uh she's gonna drop down uh she's gonna corner uh
the both of them are gonna corner uh both of you guys he's gonna go back towards uh red
she's gonna face up with Roma Roma eight feet tall this girl 410 and she's gonna go all right tell
me mister what's happening here whoa someone shorter than me what the fuck is happening someone
make this setup well i'm someone you don't want to mess with so you better mess up why am i hearing
things i have no idea you dropped the invisible thing yeah all right they just they just see a
fucking uh piece of armor just plop into existence behind them i mean what the fuck being is into
existence yeah uh and whale is gonna go whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa stop right there big guy
uh we don't want any trouble just let us be on our way first of all did you call our names
oh yeah what did you know our names you just showed up here i guess look it on the bounty
posters uh he's gonna look at the phone is gonna like okay uh and you see him disappear and he's
gonna reappear here and the phone in your hands is gone yeah sapling doesn't really care uh he's
gonna just crush the phone in his hands and uh just throw it down all right well now you know who we are
what now you probably know who i am too well we heard about you from Linus but that's about it
and i don't really trust people Linus knows
now we were here just passing by yeah you better be passing by we don't want any trouble
uh it was nice meeting you we'll be on our way then we're exactly you're going oh the the girl
yeah she go come up with the who the hell are you shorts that uh she's gonna go
you see one of her hands uh like uh she just points one of her hands in your uh
belly or something because i think that's probably where she could only reach and you see
as her hands yeah and you see as her hand turns and warves into like a pistol as you're gonna go
are you sure you want to know who i am
sure you see me that's shit uh she's gonna point the other hand towards you and she's gonna do
the same with the other hand sapling is just standing there in her giant armor
whale is like okay just drop it sarika they're not worth it just just drop it
okay Lin told us to come get you we were just testing out the waters
okay uh well i'm sapling nice to meet you well as you probably already know my name's
well see she is sarika she gets pretty hot headed sometimes so try not to get on her nerves uh yeah
that's about it also uh there's uh he's gonna go disappear again and uh he's gonna reappear after
like a couple of seconds he's gonna go like there's two more marines right outside this alley uh you
want me to take care of them are you good what do you mean by take care of them
are you now take care of them you're pirates you know what that means no no there's different
kind it's either you try to kill him you're trying to just no i will not kill him we can't kill him that's
the problem if we could kill him there there wouldn't be on this island yeah i don't i don't like killin
anyway all right sarika just stay here i'll take care of them uh you see this guy disappear again
and after like two four seconds he's gonna come back he's gonna be like okay they're gone
hey man i'm about to see and watch him take care of him epic citrus you just see like a blur
passing through and you see two of the marines just disappear and the blur just takes them with uh him
hey bro you trying to make some money
yeah i'm always up for some money what you want i'll give you
sapling let's go talk to this gentleman where people can't hear us
oh you're you're still in the you're still in the alley you can talk to him
uh sarika's gonna go head to red and she's gonna be like so uh you're pretty neat uh how did
you how did you do that how can you make people disappear
where the wind go red is here he's over he's over he's over here okay oh i can't oh that's why
that's yeah yeah yeah to go to the end of the alley yeah yeah that we don't have much time let's
drop it up pretty quick i'm just saying we have an opportunity where we're gonna be playing cards
we may need you to swap out a drink for us i'll give you 25 times yeah buddy this the people of this
town know was pretty well i don't i don't think that's gonna fly if anything goes wrong there
you just need a you just need to swap out the drink that the bartenders carrying to this person
before it gets torn you just need to use that speed i just saw you do
look i wish i could help you but it's just not in the cards man i don't know what to tell you i
can't do anything my hands are tied help me help you help me help you i i can't do it any
yeah can you do a persuasion
where's the persuasion
yeah he's not buying it it's like nah man i'm out
while you were talking to will and baptize is just standing there figuring out what the
fuck happened in front of him but uh the cerica is trying to talk to red is she asked um so how do you
how do you make people disappear is there even here
hear me yeah yeah yeah there i go
i asked nicely it played nicely it kind of gives like a little
to oh yeah red it's great oh i didn't i didn't know that was possible that's that's pretty neat
all right uh shit so what what what are we doing now
we're going back to lose office okay i guess we can pick that uh once we get there
yeah saffel is gonna say it's a sevika you have a deal for it cool
well i thought the the uh this person also had the first she points at red so i was like
curious maybe she made you disappear but i guess not i don't know they're a big musician
huh then no music can do that but okay um she is it's cool music
aha she gets more and more confused as long as you talk yeah exactly all right uh okay i think i think
we can end it here you have options i mean we're almost tried to talk to will but uh even if he did
like maybe 15 it'd be still be hard to convince him to uh help you with the um
orade or whatever we don't need them all right uh
stars and wishes anything that you like to uh happen next time or something
you don't have time right now you can send it to me later